terminus lewis je suis ton oncle
johnattan tu es habillée en robe de
chambre c'est pas kimono nous y voilà
notre petit chez nous
[Musique]
tu es lewis je présume le voyage est à
prix réduit est chouette et ma voisine
je me réjouis de constater que tu n'as
pas hérité de la tête démesurément
volumineuse de ton oncle miracle le
squelette violette ou racornie viens de
parler
tu verras cet endroit est tout à fait
surprenant
tu peux aller visiter
il n'y a absolument aucun danger
ces sondes en jeu ce truc tant qu'il a
le ventre plein tu sais ce qu'est un
mage lewis on nomme sorcier je crois que
comme sorciers c'est un petit peu
réducteur
tu veux dire que tu es un mage s'il te
plaît apprends moi ce peuple est
d'accord
comme tu voudras je peux te prêter les
bons livres d'apprendre les bonnes
formules mais le dernier petit pourcent
ne dépend que de toi
j'en veux pas du nabot bizarre tu crois
que j'en veux moi
coup de chance tu as tout raconter à
lewiston bah non pas tout
dans le détail
l'ancien propriétaire de la maison et et
maje lui aussi il est très mal faisant
est très puissant il ya laissé une
horloge cachés dans les murs
on ne sait pas à quoi elle sert à
paraître effrayantes
trois cours la dernière fois c'était 4
il se passera quoi quand ce ne sera plus
qu'un en tout cas rien de bon c'est sûr
nous devons détruire l'horloge
j'ai la chair de poule tu n'y arriveras
pas tout seul je peux t'aider
tu veux voir de la vraie magique je vais
te montrer
à
décidément j'aime pas ça
[Musique]